Hey, I'm a bird.
Hey guys.
Yeah, that's right.
I'm a bird now.
Funniest shit ever, guys.
They turned me into a fucking bird.
don't worry guys I also have I have arms I don't know am I
okay is that the true don't yeah that's me I'm a bird now
did you guys could you guys tell from the thumbnail that was
gonna be a bird yeah that's right full body tracking is this
the sound okay?
I've evolved.
Bro, okay.
Have you ever seen a bird shake its tail?
Yeah.
I could also do this.
I can extend, extend my neck a little bit.
The sound is okay.
Oh, that's great.
That's good to know.
That's all I need to know.
Anyway, yeah, hey guys, this is not the announcement, by the
way.
Don't worry, this is not the announcement, guys.
I need to fix my head, I need to fix my, my, myself a bit
more.
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
I think that's better.
All right, so anyway, this is not the announcement.
If you guys want to know what the announcement is, you got
to wait until the very end.
But for now, we got to enjoy some, some dokey birds.
Whoa.
okay so like i actually have like i can do different things
with it so like hey i can be i can be a little happy and
then whoa my god and then i can be i can be can just be sad
i bet this is sad but i can be sad and then i could be like
whoa huh
huh and then i could change my eye color so it's oh wait
that's the mirror oh my god wait that's a mirror sorry i
didn't know what mirrors are okay after becoming a bird
realized that that's a mirror like oh my god that was the
fucking mirror where where's the camera where wait a minute
where's the camera then if that's the mirror okay sorry now
i'm facing the camera where the fuck is the camera where
sorry um i didn't realize uh that was the that was the the
mirror so yeah yeah so I have hands actually okay so this
was done by I'm so sorry I forgot the name of the creator I
saw them post it post like a crow model and I was like oh my
god I want one because it was so funny I was like oh my god
dokey bird is real dokey bird is real
oh my god she's real so so so I had I had to I don't know
where the camera went guys where did the camera go I needed
to face me guys I can't find a camera oh no I haven't been
in VR chat in so long I don't I don't know where I don't
know Where the camera is wait, okay.
Wait, okay.
What if I okay?
If I do smooth.
No, it can't be that Where did it go?
Where did the camera go guys?
I actually don't know where it went Where did it go?
Why is there two doki because like the thing behind me.
It's a it's a mirror Where where's the camera?
Wait, I can't, oh, I found it, I found the camera, okay,
guys, all right, now it should face me now, oh, oh, well,
oh, sorry, that's my head, oh, that's not good, oh, okay,
sorry, guys, this crow lost its, this crow doesn't, doesn't
really have hands, I'm sorry, I don't, I don't know what I'm
doing, okay, auto level, oh, there we go, look, now I'm in
the ground, Okay, let me pull it back up a little bit.
Look guys, oh my god, my leg.
Oh my leg, what's going on with my leg?
What's going on with my leg?
Guys, give me a sec.
Guys, the crow is not doing so well.
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
Now, okay, now it feels a lot better.
Okay, okay.
So, sounds good, right?
The sound is, the sound is okay.
right guys is it sound guy i'm sorry but like i okay you
said sound is okay okay nice sound is okay okay that's good
well anyway guys before we go on our little before we go on
our little adventure um i just say i have a gift for you uh
but like so like the gift is like unrelated to um i'm sorry
i can't i can't
okay anyway so like so the the gift whoa the gift is
unrelated to um oh my god but look at me walk look at how i
walk wee look okay look it's like i i really enjoy the
simple things in life because like look at this whoa
huh huh oh whoa okay anyway anyway as i was saying as i was
as i was saying so like okay so um so there's actually
there's actually more there's actually uh more to this so
like the thing is i did say there's gonna be a gift right so
like the gift is unrelated to the announcement So let me let
me grab well, there's like several there's like more than
one gift.
So let me let me let me oh wait no, but I can do like I
think you do different expressions.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
So yeah, yeah, guys.
Okay, hey, I forgot I could I could do different expressions
with like my hands.
there's several gifts so I should get the I should get the
first gift for you guys give me a sec let me let me let me
grab it real real fast is the gift you migrating is it now
is what you migrating for the self okay okay it's summer
it's already it's not winter anymore mid what do you mean
okay anyway all right me a sec let me all right so there's
actually there's actually uh there's actually uh several
several gifts okay hey okay i'm not the crow was the the red
hair but yes i do have an Actual 3 and he cheat me.
I do.
Bring the crow.
What do you mean?
What do you mean bring the crow back?
Look at me.
Also, I have full body tracking right now.
So, yeah.
It's like, oh, you don't remember my dance.
I don't.
What do you mean?
Hey in the cre... Okay, so.
So, what does this mean?
All right, let me... Where did I put this?
Where did I?
Okay, so there's supposed to be like an image that shows up.
So the first you oh, what's that sound?
What's that sound?
Oh, that's my logical logitech G Pro wireless.
Okay Dada!
Oh shit, where is it?
Okay, we'll put it here.
I'm sorry.
I'm professional.
Okay, now where am I?
Oh, no, that's different.
Look!
yes it's not in stores yet but like it's like whoa be
prepared be prepared guys so so yes this is made by preachy
rigging done by entity you might recognize those names um i
was so happy that uh preachy wanted to work with me on uh
the chibi 3d model i always loved her models And the thing
is, the thing is, I wanted to work with her because I wanted
her to make plushies!
I've wanted to have like chibi plushies based off of like,
you know, my chibi 3D models.
So like that was like the main reason.
Can I even say, okay, that was like the main reason why I
wanted to work with her.
So like, yes!
Yes!
It's not going to be up in stores for a bit because like I
want to make sure it looks okay before I don't want you guys
to like pre-order and then like wait a year because we were
going through like pre-production so like it's more so like
you know a sneak peek of like uh of it going to you want the
crow what about this where are you guys what about this what
do you mean you want the
look at me I can raise my legs I can kick what do you mean
the crow okay the crow could kick the crow could barely
extend its arms look I can like T pose and everything what
do you mean wait what do you mean you missed the bird I am
the bird I am the bird it's literally donkey bird okay in
the future we'll have you You literally met the crow for
like, for like 10 minutes.
How do you already fall in love with the bird?
How do you, what is this working?
Princess and the frog shit.
How do you fall in love with the bird already?
It's been 10 minutes.
Anyway, anyway.
Um, but yes, this was like the main reason why I really,
really, really wanted to work with Preachie for this model.
I really wanted to have plushies and I felt like her style
was, what works.
so well in a plushie form so I was like super excited I was
like yes yeah so so I'm really happy to be able to work with
her and like being able to you know I mean look at it it's
so cool it's so cute yeah anyway it took a while to find a
world for this so i didn't i didn't know what world to go to
i just literally was like oh i was looking at animal
crossing worlds and then um because we don't have any actual
personal 3d world because that's a lot of work and i already
have like a million other projects ongoing with right now so
like a 3d world is sort of like you know not not in the near
future not in the next coming months guys so I had to like
borrow some worlds while I was exploring uh VR chat and I
was like oh my god like I even went to like I even looked at
like Pokemon mystery dungeon worlds and everything and then
uh the perfect one was literally Minecraft because I needed
an open field I needed I needed um I needed like an open
field and I was like okay this is this is an open field it's
it's minecraft it's it's minecraft it's an open field but
yeah so that is gift wait where's my arm this is where's my
arm is this my arm oh okay this is gift number one gift
number two gift number two is basically you see this this is
gonna be for free for all you guys you can do anything you
want with the 3d model so um it will be uploaded later on
sketch fab um and you will be able to download it and do
whatever fuck you want but like like you know not really
everything you want
i won't be putting the crow though the crow is exclusively
for me so um no crow though no crows but the the uh the this
will be for you guys you can do what you want make animation
put me in a game that you're making uh mod me into something
anything you want to do um as long as you don't monetize it
that's all i ask for as long as you don't make money off of
it i mean if you were making a video and you're using this
that's fine but as long as you don't make like physical
products and like mass produce them and make money out of it
then no because i'm gonna do that you can't do it because
i'm gonna do that so you're not allowed to no no crow
because the crow i didn't ask permission if i could because
like i i i i don't know i didn't ask permission if i could
put it up for public because it's like it's their crow model
and i asked them they could risk in it to me and oh my god
you guys really want okay fine i'll be the crow all right
where am i all right there you go are you happy are you are
you look i'll advertise my plushie as a crow so yes um
i'll get i'll give the dragoons what they want so yes um
this will be put for pre-orders maybe in in a month or or
two i don't know i'm still we're going through
pre-prediction right now and it's so hard making plushies
because it's like they send you like for you know like for
anyone that's ever made a plushie before the first first
draft is looks fucking ridiculous and it looks like really
bad and you have to go through like ass before it looks good
so like i want to be sure that we have like an actual good
looking plushie before i put it up for pre-order so yes you
gotta wait like a month or maybe two i don't not sure but i
just wanted to show you guys maybe a month maybe the month
later you might notice the store is uh the store is offline
right now because um when it's back online it's gonna look
so cool like it took us a long time to like um get that
store ready for you guys but there's gonna be like new stuff
on it and uh it's gonna look or maybe not actually no i
remember one of my staff members were like yeah there's not
gonna be the news products aren't gonna be on it yet uh but
yes lots of stuff was being shipped out apparently white
distributor told me that like they shipped out like 2 000
plus products already in like within a week so that was
fucking crazy i was like I can I can actually like um I can
actually like work on new stuff now like this and somebody's
like wait do you do he's not a tomato she's a fucking burp
this is just another this is just another skin suit so you
can imagine like a tomato like piloting like you know in
Gundam where you're in a suit just every time every time
like the tom my true form is in a different body is there's
like a tomato piloting it so so there's a tomato inside me
too don't worry guys there's a tomato inside all of us so do
not worry okay let me let me go back let me go back
but uh well where am i okay so like i'm really excited
because i can't wait to make uh merch based off of uh based
off of uh my chibi form so like i mean like whoa i love
working with her she her her style is so her style is so
cute and um we went through like so many drafts uh because
oh my gosh i'll show you guys the sketches of that in
another stream um but like i went through Dress when it came
to like what it was gonna look like in terms of like the
shape of everything Because I'm like such a perfectionist
and everything so I'll show you guys in the next what's my
next stream I'll show you guys on Monday because I don't
stream on Sunday.
I'll show you guys on Monday
I'm gonna make you guys watch Sandland
I'll be streaming Sandland on Monday and I'm gonna make you
guys watch it if you guys want to see the behind the scenes
you have to watch sand lad oh yes anyway uh let me i need to
put this away now uh i need to get on the rest of the screen
anyway so um i do have i don't have any props well i do have
one prop but like i said there's still the announcement um i
have this wait wait wait a minute where's where is it wait i
thought i had this wait give me a sec give me a sec i need a
sorry i'm gonna go big for a sec guys okay i'm gonna become
big all right watch this oh my god where am i oh my god why
is it i can't see okay okay there we go all right so i'm big
now
as as i was saying we do have the announcement oh my gosh
where's my arm okay is this the announcement is in this gift
box chat the announcement is in this gift box oh my gosh how
do i how do i how do i open the lid
give me a sec where's my hand
a second here oh my god but can't i open it guys we will you
will have your announcement when i figure out how to open
this box okay my hand is here all right please please oh my
god for the love of god i will learn how to open a box guys
guys i swear to god okay okay give me a sec all right We'll
figure this out.
Okay, guys, today's stream, we're going to figure out how to
open a box.
Okay.
Where's my hand going to?
Oh,
Anthony, I don't see anything.
I just see inside my head.
Anthony, we have a problem.
I thought I tested everything but I didn't test the big
model all I see I see the inside of my head so I have to
look at the camera the figure out where's my hand all right
this is the present hand this is the present hand this is
this is my hand this entire stream will be me figuring we
won't get the announcement until I figure this out guys we
will we okay anyway okay this is gonna be a test I'm not
giving you the announcement yet I'm gonna test this out
where are you you're gonna okay okay this is oh no I put the
lid back on no
I put the lid back on Okay Guys, give me a sec Okay We're
gonna figure We're gonna figure this out Guys Where's my
hand?
Okay Alright Come on, lid Get off Lid Lid Lid Okay, guys
We'll deal with that later I will future future doki will
figure we'll figure that out for future doki will figure
that out another time because because i don't know how to do
it i don't i don't know we'll figure it out entity are you
watching entity entity please i'm sorry i lied i was like i
know you said you were like make sure let me know if
everything is okay.
And like, I was like, just finished testing it.
Um, I think everything is good.
I lied.
I was trying to find worlds to go to.
I'm sorry.
I lied.
I thought it was fixed.
I didn't think you, I didn't think.
I didn't think.
That like, I can open the box.
It's a box.
What do you mean?
I can't open the box.
I'm sorry.
I'm freaking out.
I'm sorry, Anthony.
Please.
Okay.
I'm sorry.
I won't lie again.
She says that she naturally lied.
But for real this time, I won't lie again.
So anyway, um, I guess we could explore.
this entire stream was just me wanting to show you guys this
oh my gosh I look like those the super Saiyan pose the what
was it you know like when all of them are all the bad guys
the bad guys again they're like the super Saiyan squad or
like the Saiyan squad or whatever and they're like oh
yes the Jin Yu the Jin Yu Force the Jin Yu Force yeah I'm so
sorry for a lot of Dragon Ball Z fans are gonna send me hate
mail now uh yeah like like that let's go get a green screen
you guys deserve a green screen world um let's see a search
world green green screen wait maybe i can just search up
green i'm a professional green okay selfie and green screen
joined like a public minecraft world for like vr on accident
before the stream started and they were like children and i
was like oh my god kids can have vr headsets now like what
the oh my god what's worse than ipad kids vr kids all right
children that's worse than that's that's worse than ipad
kids
you.
Where's my camera?
Where is it?
Oh, world.
Guys, I always struggle trying to find my- Oh, is that the
camera?
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
All right.
Yeah!
Wait, that's not a green screen.
What the fuck is that?
Okay, where's the- where's- wait, where my camera go that's
not a green screen there's like a square a gray square
where's my camera camera sorry i'm always struggling trying
to find my camera camera where are you oh there you are okay
now yes okay professional i am a professional all right
let's auto level look at me yes look at me all right so so
now now I have the green screen so I can be like and then be
like but I don't remember the newer one I haven't seen the
newer one enough like I know like guys I've only been
streaming for like three to four months guys I don't
remember guys my memory is not as good as it used to be got
i got brain rot uh okay and then and then i would have like
the trophy tomato there and then I would one time I'll be
like yay you know for the dragon I'll be like yay and then
and I don't remember I actually oh I don't remember oh my
god oh my god you know I used to I could have got a master's
degree you know I used to be a straight A student what
happened to me what happened to me okay okay so um so oh
yeah i forgot i forgot there's like different expressions i
have different expressions so i can you know i can smile be
like yeah yeah sorry i saw that short about like the avatar
for keeping up with kardashians and then and then top was
like yeah so it's sort of like in my head stuck in my head
for a little bit now and then yeah I have the sparkle eye
yeah oh wait fuck okay oh shit I'm I'm cringing.
I'm like cringing.
Alright.
I'm going to be...
I'm going to be smug.
Hey.
Okay.
And then...
I can be the other smug.
I'll be like...
Hey.
And then...
And then there's this one.
Wait.
Where's my hand?
There it is.
Oh, okay, wait, wait, wait.
Ah, because I want to open that.
Ah, okay, and then.
Oh, wait, no, that's sad, because I'm crying.
You can see here.
I'm actually crying.
Sorry.
Wrong way.
This one is the...
Anyway, what else?
Oh, yeah.
Let me just, let me...
Oh, it's looking at me.
me no don't look at me and uh and your fucking oshi is here
wait am i here wait where am i am i not moving where's my
camera no the world is all green so i don't know where i am
the world is all green where am I guys give me a sec I'm
trying to figure out where I am I am trying oh my god look
oh there I am guys I figured out where I am guys look at me
I'm prancing I am prancing yeah I couldn't figure out where
I was oh my the entire world was just green it was so scary
i couldn't tell oh wait but you need the green screen fuck
okay uh okay wait give me a sec i need prance to a green
okay there we go guys i'm figuring it out okay now i can
prance look at that yay whoa whoa wait where am i Is this?
Oh, there I am.
Okay.
All right.
I still need I always need to figure out where I am There
you go.
All right, so So I can okay, okay, let me I can be like whoa
and I can Move my neck like that and be like hey guys Yeah,
that's right.
That's right.
This is your oh she right here
but yes i can i can change my eye color but i like the the
black eyes better i feel like it fits it and i can like
remove the pins and i could be like wow yeah and then i can
do like
yeah yeah and then the sparkle and happy and then i have and
i have some like cursed ass wings i guess like like i can
fly i can be like i'm
sorry i think i have the most one with this one the most for
sure
wait can i do the intro dance on as as the bird okay i mean
it looks wonky i feel like maybe like this but wait where am
i where am i oh sorry i feel like i'm an old person being
like where am i i'm lost in the supermarket but
bomb bomb bomb okay I want my arms extended now I'm gonna
sit down what does it look like when I sit down let's see
where's my camera oh my god there
you go okay okay all I'm saying is if you see a fucking bird
that's sitting like this the bird has issues like it's
actually not good a bird should not be sitting down if you
see a wild bird that's sitting like this please call a
veterinarian or I don't know do something a bird should not
be sitting down it's not natural but oh my god look amazing
as a
okay I look so fucking stupid but like
I'm just a virtue okay let me let me uh go back to go back
to oh hey oh I look look look see guys guys look I look
fantastic I know oh my god the tracking is so good so good
I love just like being able to just sit down like this guys
no you guys don't want the bird back stop lying stop lying
to yourselves guys stop lying to yourselves I know you guys
don't actually want the bird back guys okay I know I know I
know that you don't actually want the bird back but yes I
have full body tracking right now I'm sitting down because I
want to know what it looks like when I'm sitting down and I
guess like
Wow My people need me guys.
I can touch my toes Look, it's not my fault.
My arms are short my it's not it's not my fault my arms are
short
My people need me goodbye now
okay um um anyway uh i think that's that's really it i just
really wanted to do uh i just really wanted to do this
stream for the sake of showing you guys this i know i said
like let's visit some worlds you know what no let's visit
one world we'll visit one world guys before i wait okay wait
was entity in chat Sorry, Entity.
I don't know what you said.
Guys, parrot what Entity said to us in chat.
What did Entity say?
What's the announcement?
No, that's what I'm saying.
I'll do, like, maybe I'll go to a visit, one world, and
then, uh, and then, um, and then, oh, okay, okay.
Wait, do I have to restart?
Entity, do I have to restart?
do I have to oh wait I can take I forgot guys there was one
thing I can be bald oh my god that looks so wrong that looks
so fucking wrong yes I can take off my hat but I don't I
don't like that I look like some fucking generic anime girl
now with all my hat chat to be fair I actually look oh I
look like I look so generic without my hat the past what
makes me special um anyway okay let's get back up I just
want to know what it looks like when I when I sit down um
but yes let's see let us see if it's fixed now do I have to
restart I don't know we'll find out I don't have to rest
okay okay guys I'm gonna wait oh god okay look at me auto
level okay nice and then auto level but where am i where oh
no i'm too big now okay auto level okay there we go and then
i'll be here okay guys we're gonna do a demonstration of the
announcement slash gift we're gonna practice a little bit
okay here it is I can see it now but
okay guys give me a sec we're gonna we're gonna figure this
out okay please please why is this so difficult entity I'm
sorry this is what I mean when I said I'm so bad at gestures
okay we're gonna figure this out guys we're gonna okay hey
the first step the moment i figured this out we can go to
the world and i can give you your announcement okay firmly
grasp it i'm firmly grasping it i'm okay is this he said
rock and roll oh I did it wait where's the camera camera is
okay camera is somewhere here because that's where I'm
looking at where did that camera go where where are you
you're you're here somewhere you're here you're in front of
me oh there you are there you are okay all right That's what
we're trying to do.
Okay And then wait, this is the wrong arm for this
Oh my god, what's this POV don't eat you Guys, I'm
practicing I'm practicing right now.
Okay, okay guys I figured it out.
Entity, I figured it out this time.
I did it.
Are you proud of me?
I fucking did.
I'm sorry.
I will never lie to you again.
Alright.
Okay.
Let's go to...
Let's go to a...
Oh, this would be the perfect place.
I wanted to go here for...
No, this is a random world.
No.
This is... This is a public world.
No!
No, no children, please.
No children.
That's all I ask.
Oh god, okay.
Worlds.
I've been getting a lot of like messages, I think on
Discord, but like I don't know like, uh, oh no, where am I?
Okay.
Uh, new instance.
Invite.
Okay, there we go.
Thank god.
I was freaking out there.
Thought I was gonna get, you thought I was gonna get
children again.
Um, so good thing, good thing it's not kids.
good thing uh not children okay all right let's go back to
small um where's my camera this is like my entire world just
where's my camera dude where's my car all right camera oh
there you are guys I think this is a good spot to you know
to let have like look is this a great spot to see your gift
it's like it's the Pokemon mystery dungeon world where you'd
like almost died and get reincarnated as a Pokemon look
isn't it so cute I love I love Pokemon mystery dungeon it's
one my favorite it's literally one my favorite Pokemon
series despite all the shit I say about Pokemon new version
new version Pokemon.
Pokemon Mystery Dungeon on the DS.
That shit was fire.
That was peak.
Peak Pokemon for me.
And that and Crystal.
Pokemon Crystal and Pokemon Mystery Dungeons.
Peak Peak Pokemon for me.
We don't talk about the newer Pokemon games.
I'm sorry if you guys actually like the newer Pokemon games.
But yeah.
Okay.
Alright guys.
So, I know I said, like, we're visiting VR chat worlds, yay,
but that was sort of like a clickbait type thing.
Well, I mean, we visited this world.
We visited three worlds, technically.
So, like, I did my thing.
I didn't clickbait because I did say we're visiting VR chat
worlds, and that was three worlds.
And mostly, I just wanted to, like, show you guys this.
Whoa.
Yeah.
and then that's me teabagging you um oh i should have been a
green screen fuck
god damn it that should have been a fucking green screen all
right um video editors you can crop out all that background
you know and then i wanted to showcase this for you guys
because i mean i mean come on i look fucking cute
and also your new favorite oh she crowbird like I don't know
crowbird dokey crow crow dokey I don't know I don't know
what sounds good I mean you could just literally be like
dokeybird because it's literally a bird oh my gosh my legs
my fucking legs um what was I gonna say oh yeah yeah it's
gift time oh it's on beak sorry I was like wait is it
where's the gift oh my god i'm gonna eat the sun oh you
can't come out of the ocean like like godzilla okay
okay um all right all right it's gift time wait the camera's
so tiny now No, the camera's not here VR chat, please can
you make the camera more noticeable?
I don't ask for much.
I just want to know where the fuck the camera is VR chat.
This is all I ask you.
Where's the camera?
Okay, you're You're here, which means you're below me, which
means you're somewhere here, but like where?
I'm not blind.
It's literally so hard to see.
It's different.
Okay.
Don't look at me.
Okay, and then maybe I can find it here.
Where are you?
Please.
This is literally all we need.
I can't end it until I find the camera.
Where could you be?
You should be blue.
no no this is not it that's not the camera okay it's like a
blue dot but like you're clearly here somewhere but like
where oh there you are you're so fucking tiny holy shit
you're like literally a dot okay no no no no no if you see
what i see you're literally just a dot for me okay there it
is to see that like okay all right for real now for real
okay box all right guys I have it's announcement time you've
all waited for this everybody it's finally it's finally
announcement time guys as soon as I open this box we're
gonna get our announcement give me a sec give me a give me a
sec as soon as we open this box okay
the moment I open this box okay come on please for the love
of God please open that's all I ask you that's all I ask why
is this so oh I see the lid open oh do you guys see that the
lid is opening but i never could get it right and i don't
know why okay all right where did the camera go okay give me
a sec okay camera is somewhere here camera is like okay guys
no no it's not empty i swear to god it's it's not empty
it'll show up the moment I find the camera.
Where are you?
It's not empty!
It's stuck to the box at the end.
It's like, there's like a hidden compartment.
It's a hidden compartment.
I just need to find you guys.
Okay.
All right.
Now let me move a little bit closer.
Okay, fuck.
Sorry.
Take two.
Okay.
Don't worry, guys.
I have a secret gift for you.
give me a sec guys i'm a professional give me a sec it's
gonna work all right in three two one oh my god three two
one guys wait why am i not actually mirror myself yeah
That's right!
Oh my god.
Sorry, I'm a mess right now.
That's right!
New skin suit is done!
It will be June 22nd next week at 5 p.m.
PST.
So what does that mean about the old skin suit?
I mean, you literally just revealed.
You just literally just revealed your, like, cheapy 3D model
and, like, you know, your cheapy, not as cheap you're your
crowbird model and also like the plushie and everything are
you just not gonna care about that old skin suit no this
skin suit is still a part of me it just means it's like a
new outfit you know but like instead of like regular normies
like normie vtubers where they like you know change clothes
i can change skin suits
gonna be the main primary skin suit.
This would be like retro doki.
Okay?
This is gonna be like retro doki.
We might not see retro doki anymore or not a lot.
Maybe like 1% in the future.
But like she's still a part of me.
And like I'm still gonna be selling merch of retro doki.
And like have retro doki and make like cameos and stuff.
So yes because the true form is the tomato inside of us all
along.
it's here I think the timid is right here it's not in my
stomach I it's not not in my stomach it's like in my head
okay because the true form is inside of me in here in the in
the head right here like I think in one of there so um so
yes um um retro doki might not make much appearance after
the 22nd um every any future merch um unless we're doing
like retro stuff like you know the altar girl doki and all
stuff like that like we're still gonna make merch out of
that and like have like uh stands of that and stuff like
that like chibi stuff for all my past iterations uh as doki
and all my outfits as doki we're still gonna do that stuff
um but moving forward for like sponsors brand deals uh
future streams future identity will be new skin suit so look
forward to the news I hope you guys like music and see I was
so scared like I was so nervous about my new skin suit
because I don't I don't know it's different you sort of saw
the silhouette it is different so I hope you guys it's like
a combination of past present and future so like i grew i
feel like i grew a lot um as a content creator uh over the
years um i might not feel like i'm like this as much as i
used to in the past you know um and it is pretty a pretty
old skin suit it is a pretty old skin suit um so like it was
time for an upgrade design-wise and like personality like
how I feel on the outside um to match more of how I feel on
the inside so that's why uh um I do hope you guys like it
like we went through so many me and my new mama went through
so many drafts and then I got my old mama to help me as well
to figure out what exactly I wanted and uh but yeah Yeah, y
'all.
All I'm saying is that you might be like, wow, Doki, was it
because of the new fallout show with the...
No, it was not because of the ghoul.
I had that idea before the ghoul was a thing.
And then, like, so then I need to tell you guys right now, I
did not got inspired by the ghoul.
My mama had the idea of, okay, so the idea is like a bounty
hunter, and I was like, oh my god, that's so good.
That's such a, that's such a good idea.
And then I saw, and then the, and then like a month later,
the fucking ghoul popped up, and I was like, what the fuck?
So I'll tell you guys right now, I mean, it's obvious, like
the trailer, it was like a bounty hunter theme, but like,
yes, the theme is bounty hunter.
so that is all I'm going to give you guys in terms of like
hints and stuff you'll find out next week on what it is
anyway guys that's really all I want to do for the stream it
was a short stream but next week it's going to be a lot next
week we have also have a collab with mint next week we're
going to be playing a spooky game so we have that and then
We have SandLand!
I'm gonna talk about everything on the Sandland stream, so
you better come!
Cause I know none of you guys actually watched the Sandland
stream, so.
If you wanna know Bihanna scenes and maybe more hints about
my new skin suit, you better come through the Sandland
stream on Monday, cause I know not a lot of people want to
watch Sandland, but I'm gonna make you guys watch Sandland.
I know.
I know Sandland is not like very popular but you guys have
that you want to know about behind the scenes for everything
you gotta come
hey guys as always everybody stay oh wait where's the camera
as always everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and
move around to get that blood flowing and if you suffer me
head to bed because you deserve it i'll see you guys next
time everybody bye guys bye okay guys i need to shimmy over
to the opiates the transition isn't as seamless as i thought
it's gonna be bye